what the Saudi government stuff you've
been openly critical of the Saudi
government and then you got a letter in
the mail from a fan what was in it what
was the reaction yeah I don't know who
sent it but after a couple of our
episodes somebody found out where we
lived
there was an envelope it was filled with
white powder to your house yeah to our
house and um that's scary yeah it's
terrifying and and you know that's when
you kind of realize there is there is
blowback to your your materials does
that mean when you now write a joke do
you run it through multiple filters one
of those filters being is this going to
lead to me or my family being in danger
yeah I think one of the things that I
think about now is hey you're saying
something it's going to be in 190
countries and now because of the
internet everyone's going to be able to
see it if you stand by this right and
the repercussions that may come with it
so it's like number one is it funny
number two absolutely yeah and do I
stand by it and the repercussions that
could come with it